c'est raté de jeunes août à vtt
[Musique]
un truc alors qu'il m'a fait graver
marie ce que tu m'as dit un truc qui
souffre
tu m'a dit tu es contente de revenir
pourquoi ouais je suis contente de
revenir et à tel point que j'ai même
hâte de me prendre du chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la mer du nord en ballon
[Musique]
il faut
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais pas de bisous vous n'êtes pas de
bisous
je n'ai pas le niveau
j'aime courir sur de lourdes ses joies
cas rater deux jeux tout american est au
gré d'un gasquet lui perd 5 à côté d'une
porsche over rouge ouaret sur la beauté
[Musique]
toi
partout
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
ménard
[Musique]
ouais